Speaker 1: Failed former President Donald Trump,
who's been indicted twice and impeached twice and
may be indicted one, two or three more times,
is now wildly accusing President Joe Biden of
cocaine use. This happened on his platform. Truth
Social Circle. The back story here is that there
was cocaine found in a visitor's area of the
White House. Right wing media quickly jumped
to suggest that it. Might be Hunter Biden's. Fox
News host Brian KILMEADE suggested it might be
laced with fentanyl. They pronounce it fentanyl.
Whatever. You know what they're talking about.
And now the failed former president is saying
maybe it was Biden's tro thing on troth. Essential
quote. Was Crooked Joe Biden on cocaine? Why is
cocaine capitalized? We don't know. Was Crooked
Joe Biden on cocaine when he instructed the
fbi doj to illegally invade my home Mar a
Lago in complete and total violation of my Fourth
Amendment rights? Was he on Capital C, cocaine or
various other substances when he, for the first
time in U.S. history, had his political opponent
who was leading him in the capital polls by a lot,
indicted and arrested twice, if you include the
DOJ run Manhattan DA's office. We are a nation
in decline, capital, all capital letters. Here
is my translation. This one is a very easy one
to translate. Just this might be approaching me.
I may be held accountable for my actions and
I am really, really scared. People asked me,
David, could this be defamation against Joe Biden?
I didn't even talk to a lawyer about this one. It
seems very hard to imagine how a figure as
public and powerful and as well protected
as the president of the United States, could
successfully sue Trump for defamation, even at
the suggestion that he is on cocaine. Now, I want
to mention one other thing. And this, of course,
this is one the conspiracy theories conflict. On
the one hand, the right is saying that Biden has
absolutely no energy. He he looks the opposite of
coked up in every public appearance. And at the
same time, Trump is suggesting without evidence
that Biden might be using cocaine. Don't you think
that if Biden was using cocaine, he would be more
energetic rather than less energetic? I don't know
just the question that I'm asking. But again, this
is where we are. This is the former president of
the United States asserting without any evidence,
suggesting without evidence that the current
president of the United States, who beat him
by many votes nationally, may be using cocaine.